ladies vmas matt gala global citizen
live are you all exhausted
in a good way in a very good way booked
busy and blessed i feel like absolutely
it's you two right there tell us why it
was important for you to be here tonight
yeah it was so important for us to be
here tonight because we all we ever want
to do is just share our gift of music
and our voice for good and to kind of
pay it forward because we've been
inspired by incredible artists out there
and music just makes us so happy and
tonight it was so freeing for me and to
know that we were doing it for good and
just rewarding all the beautiful people
out there who have done so much good in
the world as well it felt incredible
your performance was spectacular and you
had some water works you had tears
rolling down your face
[Music]
[Music]
what was going through your mind on
stage yes i just got really emotional
because there's so many beautiful beings
including my sister who just
surround me with love
and i just really felt it in that moment
on that stage and i was just it felt
surreal
what was your
reaction in that moment i was just like
oh my gosh my sister she's crying oh
it's so sweet she is such a loving heart
and it was so much fun to be up there
with her so i'm just so grateful and had
a great time and that glam is still on
point no eyelashes lost no mascara right
they touched us up
you look amazing well like we mentioned
you guys are booked busy and blessed
doing your own solo things right now
different projects acting what are you
most excited for people to see with the
little mermaid oh my gosh uh i guess i'm
just excited for people to see it when
it comes out um yeah and to hear her
incredible voice that was my favorite
thing what was your favorite part about
the whole experience
i think the fact that it was just so
different from what i'm used to and i
was i kind of threw myself into this
like
adventure of like
just
escape and like wonder and it really
felt like a magical world that i was
living in for nine months so yeah i feel
really grateful i'm just excited for
everyone to see it later you gotta say a
whole new world next time and then you
can get into aladdin next
do you think you really got the acting
bug known you know it's definitely fun i
might do more yeah i like that you might
do more now obviously you both have a
lot on your plates with different
projects do you have time to still work
on new music together absolutely you
know even tonight it was so fun being on
that stage together and like our third
album is going to be really special so i
can't wait because we're both finding
ourselves on our own and also together
as well so it's going to be really nice
and you have your solo debut album
coming out soon i read that you are
wrapping it up with bad [ __ ] energy
so what can we expect
well i
appear more confident on the outside
than i actually am so the lyrics are
actually me
telling what i would tell myself in the
mirror to make myself feel more
and confident so i can't wait for people
to hear it it's definitely more pop and
more fun i love the dance so it's
exciting and have mercy just came out so
that's really special and i'm just
grateful to god and i can't wait for
more that whole vmas performance i was
like have mercy literally it was iconic
and you know a lot of people on social
media after we're drawing similarities
to beyonce and acknowledging how
important it is to have a mentor in this
business what has her support meant to
you and both of you in your journeys
beyonce's support has meant everything
to us like we
i pinch myself still because it's queen
bee yeah and you know what everyone says
it's a huge compliment so i'm grateful
for it all i just hope to even get an
ounce of her success that she has had
and i'm just going to keep grinding and
so is my sister and it's going to be a
fun journey